hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well one of the
aspects of the form of existentialism
that jean-paul Sartre articulates in
existentialism as a humanism as well as
in his novels and in his philosophical
works is an insistence that people not
make excuses for themselves for the
kinds of people that they become or for
others and that they judge people on the
basis of what it is that they actually
choose and do and start says that a
person and I'm translating here putting
it into more gender-neutral language a
person is nothing but their plan or
project project in French what it is
that they intend they exist only to the
extent that they fulfill themselves oh
yeah these day they bring themselves
into reality or they produce themselves
and he says they are nothing but the
ensemble of their acts the totality of
their act nothing else but their life so
if we wanted to express this and
somewhat more slangy language what you
see is what you get now of course this
doesn't mean that everything is
going to be there on the surface
sometimes you'd have to actually like
dig in and do some historical research
to know that this person behaved in this
way rather than what the public image of
them is but a person is what it is that
they have made of themselves through
their choices through their actions they
are responsible for the being that they
currently are or end up being sort
thinks that this applies to everyone
across the board throughout all of
history everyone coming
this is a basic existentialist constant
and he notes that some people would not
like to hear this because they want to
make excuses they make excuses for
themselves saying that you know they
could have been or should have been
something else they have a self-image
what it is that they would like to
project what it is that they would like
themselves to have been and there's this
discrepancy between what they actually
are and what they do and this image or
this whatever it's going to be a verbal
formula I am such-and-such right I am a
beautiful person who always does the
right thing and has the highest aims
well there's a huge discrepancy between
the reality of who I am and that and
it's not just because human beings are
complex it has to do with what a person
has actually chosen what they've made of
themselves and he says that people you
know in order to bear their wretchedness
their unhappiness they say circumstances
have been against me what I've been and
done doesn't show my true Worth to be
sure I've had no great love no great
friendship but that's because I haven't
met a man or woman who was worthy and it
could be that perhaps they didn't meet a
man or woman who was worthy but the main
reason they didn't have a great
friendship or a great love affair is
because they didn't seek that person out
they hung on the end of the you know you
could say the dance floor's shrinking
violet never going and asking
anybody anything they never put
themselves out there and because of that
they never had the opportunity to meet
that person so the books I've written
haven't been very good because I haven't
had the proper leisure now the books you
wrote weren't pretty weren't very good
because you wrote books that weren't
very good maybe if you had additional
leisure you might have spent it on
research time or you might have spent it
frittering it away watching TV and on
social media and doing all sorts of
other things I've writers know the
temptation of cleaning up the house when
it's time to do writing things it's very
easy to find things to distract you from
that and and similarly anybody else who
does creative work
I haven't had children to devote myself
to because I didn't find a man with whom
I could have spent my life and so he
says so there remains within me and here
he's generalizing unused and quite
viable a host of propensity 'z
inclinations possibilities that one
wouldn't guess from the mere series of
things that I've done this is the
backwards looking way in which people
justify the fact that their life is not
what they would like it to have been
that in in their own viewpoint they are
really a failure it's a way for them to
deny that and say well I just wasn't
given a fair shake I didn't have the
same opportunities as everybody else
people also do this looking forward as
well they're like I'm so full of
potential you know you you know just
look at me I'm young I'm vibrant I could
be anything so trust me with this and
the existentialist would say well what
have you actually done you want to be an
intern that's fine you want me to hire
you well that's a whole different manner
you want me to collaborate with you on
writing show me your portfolio do you
want me to bring you on as a graphic
designer
let me see the the works that you've
done already because a person is what
they have actually accomplished what
they have seen through and and seen
through not just in terms of ticking off
boxes but in
entire fabric and texture of that thing
that project that they saw through with
its own successes and its own failures
people will say that I have all this
potential within me the circumstances or
they'll talk about some sort of social
determinism that made it impossible for
them to not be the kind of person that
they are and existentialists say no no
that's not the case you want to talk
about something real talk about
actuality so he says for the
existentialist there's really no other
love than the one which manifests itself
in a person being in love or we might
change that a bit in showing acts of
love if you tell somebody you love them
and you just tell it to them all the
time that doesn't mean crap from an
existentialist perspective what shows is
what you actually do which could show
itself in other words but those words I
love you only have meaning when they're
translated into either other words that
matter or actions and it would have to
be you think very consistent actions not
just once in a blue moon sort of actions
if you could similarly say I hate that
person's guts but if you're going up to
them every time you see them and you're
hanging out with them and smiling and
saying you know nice things about them
you don't hate their guts you're just
posing as somebody who hates their guts
and he goes on and talks about artists
says the genius of Proust is the sum of
proofs works
the genius of Rothstein is his series of
tragedies that's it that's all you get
you get with the person produced and
unless we find some new stuff and that's
the sum total of the person insofar as
we're considering them to be a artistic
genius he says why say Racine could have
written another tragedy when he didn't
write it persons involved in life they
leave their impress on it outside of
that there's nothing and then he says
now understandable this is going to be a
harsh way
thinking to people whose lives did not
turn out the way they want but it also
can be very useful this is why he's
putting it forward he says it prompts
people to understand that from the
existentialist perspective its realities
that matter what is made actual what is
brought to existence not he says dreams
expectations hopes these only he says
weren't enough to define a person as a
disappointed dream miscarried hopes and
negative expectations and that is to
define a person negatively it actually
seems you know from the perspective of
the person doing it that they're being
positive about stuff but they're really
stressing negativity things that didn't
come to be talked about what you
actually did think about how people
inflate their resumés for example claim
to have taught or worked or dumb things
or been in places that are prestigious
that they've never been involved with in
their life or they had just the most
tangential connection think about name
droppers who stress how you know they
know this person and this person in this
person what are they doing they're
they're trying to compensate for their
own lack of accomplishment and deal with
their own insecurities about their
self-importance and they do so by by
playing off of other people's either
gullibility or good trust or you know
things along those lines but a person
really is only what they plan and
accomplish what they intend and bring
about and if all you do is intend you're
not really bringing things about I'm
brought to mind of somebody who I knew
in high school who acquired the nickname
all talk and no do who is constantly
sketching out these grand schemes of
what we are going to do and then
whenever it came to actually doing
things you'd find him in the background
kind of receding and I saw him at a
funeral several years later after high
school and it came up to us and reminded
us who he was by invoking that very
nickname
hey I'm do you remember I'm all talk and
no do what a thing to make central in
one's own existence to determine as
one's essence so the existentialist is
taking the opposite point of view
they're being very hard-nosed about this
in order to say well you if you want to
be a great writer start writing yeah
work on it right better get used to
editing better get used to rejection
because if you want to accomplish great
things that's going to be the cost want
to be a rock and roll star
well I'm les you're a great singer and
have a great look you better learn how
to play drums or guitar or keyboards or
something like that and you better play
pretty damn good and get used to going
on the road because that's part of the
requirements for it
Sartre goes on and he says that a person
is nothing other than a series of
undertakings they are the sum the
organization the ensemble of the
relationships which make up these
undertakings so there's a connected
context there and then he says if people
throw up to us our works of fiction in
which we write about people who are soft
weak cowardly and sometimes even
downright bad he brings up his own paths
of freedom works at that time but also
you could think of this place it's not
because these people are are in the
sense of that is their nature soft weak
cowardly are bad and he talks about Zola
here he says if we were to say as Zola
did that they are this way because of
heredity the workings of environment
society because of biological or psyche
psychological determinism people would
be reassured they'd be like oh I get to
see how the other half lives oh look at
those poor bastards there look how they
can't be anything other than that Sartre
says oh no no no everyone is what they
make themselves
including the people in the slums
including the people in the Hightower's
including all of us everywhere so he
says when the existentialist writes
about a coward he says this this coward
is responsible for his cowardice he
chooses to be a coward because he
chooses not to stand up to things and
start doesn't say that there couldn't be
such a thing like nervous Constitution
there's poor blood as the common people
say there's strong constitutions but
there's no such thing as a cowardly
Constitution he says a constitution is
not an act the coward is defined on the
basis of the acts that he or she
performs people feel in a vague way that
the coward is guilty of being a coward
and this frightens them because it opens
up the possibility that they too could
in fact be cowards we are free to be
heroes or cowards or somewhere in
between and so condemning the coward as
such is scary or repugnant to many
people but the existentialist insists no
we have to take people for what they
actually become so he says these are the
reasons why I put these characters into
my novels they didn't choose to be in
the novel but within this the structure
of the novel they choose the kind of
person that they become and we display
them as they are so being an
existentialist in starts view would
require a ruthless honesty not only
about other people but about oneself as
well
you